[music]
Heat.
Hey. Hey. Hey.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Hey,
hey, hey. [music]
It's nice.
Christian.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
[music]
>> Hello everyone. Welcome.
Come on in if you're out there. We're
going to get started. My name is
Valerie. My pronouns are she, her, and
we're glad everyone's here tonight. Um,
we just have a couple of announcements.
Next week, don't forget we are having
our Christmas service next week. It'll
be at 5:00 p. p.m. right [music] here.
Um, it's going to be a family-friendly
service. So, we will have nursery for
kiddos four ages four and under.
Otherwise, everyone else is going to be
in the service with us. We're going to
sing carols, have a candle lighting
ceremony. So, please everyone come join
us. Invite friends, family. It'll be a
great time.
We also have a ramp building project
we're going to have the opportunity to
help with. Um, it's going to be on
Saturday, December 20th. If you would
like to volunteer, we need you to sign
up and you can do that by scanning this
QR code that's right behind me and that
will give you all the information and
you can sign up there.
Um, we're kind of going to be embracing
a nice rhythm of a rest. And so on
December 28th, we will not be having any
sort of service. This will be give us a
time for our volunteers to just take a
break and just spend some time at home.
So, we won't have any service then, but
we will be back all together on Sunday,
January 4th.
Finally, if you are feeling anxious
today or you're part of the disability
community or you're just feeling a
little bit extra fidgety, we have an
accessibility bucket. It's just right
over there by the table to my left.
We've got noise cancelling headphones,
fidgets, coloring sheets. Please help
yourself at any point to the service
with any of that. Um we just ask that
you return whatever you use
>> [music]
>> um back at the end of service.
These candles that are here on either
side of me are a sign of the presence of
Christ,
fully divine and fully human.
Now we exit the kingdom of noise, hurry,
and productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness, and simplicity.
sacred space,
a place for [music] prayer, worship, and
adoration.
A place to behold Christ.
Revelation [music] of God, heartbeat of
creation. Allow the unforced rhythms of
grace to find you, to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
Why don't you guys [music] go ahead and
stand with us? We're going to get
started.
>> [music]
>> Caitlyn's going to lead this one for us.
You can hold [music and singing] my hand
when you need to let [music] go.
I can be [singing] your mountain
when you're feeling valley [music] low.
I can be your street [singing] light
showing you the [music] way home
if you can hold my hand
when you [music] need to let go.
I want a house with a crowded
[music and singing]
table and a place by the fire for
everyone.
Let us take on [music and singing] the
world while we're young and able and
bring us [singing] back together [music]
when the day is done.
If we want [singing] a garden,
we're going to [music] have to sew the
seed.
Take a little happiness.
[music] Let the roots run deep.
If it's [singing] love that [music] we
give, then it's love that we reap. If we
want a garden, [singing]
we're going [music] to have to sew the
seeds.
Yeah. I want a house [music] with a
crowded
table [singing]
and a place by the [music] fire for
everyone. [singing]
Let us [music] take on the world while
we're young and able [singing and music]
and bring us back together when the day
is [singing and music] done.
The door is always open. Your pictures
on [singing and music] my wall.
Everyone's a little broken
and everyone [singing]
belongs.
Yeah, everyone [music]
I [singing]
want a house with a crowded
table [music]
and a place by the fire for [singing]
everyone. [music]
Let's take on the world while we're
young and [singing] able [music] and
bring us back together when the day is
done. and brings us back
[music and singing]
together when the day
is [music and singing] done.
Oh,
[singing]
it done.
All right, kiddos [music] can go to
their classes.
So, so grateful for our kids ministry
people. So, if you get a chance to thank
them, give them a high five, tell them a
compliment, give them a piece of good
advice that you haven't given anyone
else, do it. They deserve it. They
deserve some some love.
At this time, we are [music] going to do
uh prayers of the people. Uh, and so you
can read along with us up here on the
screen and then there'll be a moment
where we have some silence where you can
say a situation or the name of a person
uh out loud uh for the community to hold
them in the space together.
For the city of Saxi, [music] Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you
for the old and the sick, for the widow
and orphan, for the injured and
suffering. We pray to you for the poor
and [music] the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you
for the vulnerable, the marginalized,
and those unjustly [music] targeted for
their gender, sexuality, race, or other
perceived difference. We pray to you
for those experiencing loss, loneliness,
and disconnection. And for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health, we pray to you.
Lord, we know that you love us, that you
hear us. So we lift these names and
situations up to you.
For the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts. We pray to you that they may
have life and light, healing and hope,
peace and a deep sense of your presence.
Amen.
>> [music]
>> And in my [singing] mother's womb,
[music] you formed me with your hands.
Known [singing] in love by [music] you.
Before I took a breath, when I doubted,
Lord, [music] remind [singing] me I'm
wonderfully made. You're [music] an
artist and a part of the canvas [music]
and the clay.
You make [singing] all [music]
things
work together
for my [music and singing] future.
and for my [singing] good. You make all
things [music]
work together [singing]
for [music] your glory
and for your name.
[music]
There's a healing [music]
light
just beyond the clouds. Though
[music and singing] I've walked through
fire,
I see clearly [singing] now. I know
[music] nothing has been wasted.
No [singing] failure or mistake.
You're in [music] heartest and dearted.
I'm the canvas in the clay.
[music] And you [singing] make all
things
work together
for [music] my future [singing]
and for my good. You make [singing] all
things
[music]
work together. [singing]
for your glory [music]
and for [singing]
your name.
And for your [singing]
name.
And when I doubt it, Lord,
[singing and music] remind me. I'm
wonderfully made. You're an artist and a
potter. I'm the canvas and the clay. And
[singing and music] I know nothing has
been wasted.
No failure or mistake.
You're an artist and [music] aarter.
[singing]
I'm the canvas and the clay. I know
about it. [music and singing] Lord,
remind me I'm wonderfully made.
[music and singing]
You're an artist stand aarter. I'm the
chemist [singing] and the clay. And I
know nothing [music]
has been wasted.
No [singing] failure or mistake. [music]
You're an artist and a [singing] part of
[music] the
clay.
[music]
[singing]
>> [music]
>> You're [singing] not finished [music]
with me.
You're not finished with me yet. You're
not finished with [music] me.
You're not [singing] finished with me
yet. You're [music] not finished with
[singing] me.
You're not finished with me yet. [music]
You're not finished [singing] with me.
>> No, you're not finished with me. [music]
You [singing] make all things
work together
for my future [music and singing]
and for my good. May you make
[music and singing] all things
work together
[music] for your [singing] glory
and for [music] your name. [singing]
for [music and singing] your name.
Even when I don't see it, you're
[singing] working. [music]
Even when I don't feel it, you're
working. You never stop. Never stop
working. You never [music and singing]
stop. Never stop working. Even when I
don't see it, you're working. Even when
[singing] I don't feel it, you're
working. [music]
You never stop. Never stop working.
Never stop.
[music] You [singing] are here
moving in our [music] midst.
I worship you.
You [music] are [singing] here
working in this place.
I worship you.
You are way maker, [music] miracle
worker, promise keeper, light in the
darkness. [music]
My God, [singing]
that is who you are.
>> You [music] are [singing]
way maker, miracle worker, promise
keeper, light [music and singing] in the
darkness. My God, that is who you are.
>> You are here [music and singing]
touching every heart.
I [singing] worship you. [music]
I worship you.
[music] You are here [singing]
healing every heart.
I worship [music] you.
I worship you.
>> You are here [music and singing]
turning lives around.
I [music and singing] worship you.
I worship you.
You are here [singing and music]
many every heart.
I worship you. [music]
I worship you. [singing] Oh,
you [music] are way maker, miracle
worker, [singing] promise keeper,
[music] light in the darkness. My God,
that is who you [music] are. [singing]
You are way maker, [music] miracle
worker, promise keeper, light [singing]
in the darkness. My God, that [music] is
who you are. [singing]
That is who you [music] are.
That is who you are. [singing]
That is who you are.
That [music] is who you are.
That is who [music and singing] you are.
That is who you are.
That is who you [singing] are.
Yeah.
That is [music] who you are.
>> [music]
>> That's who you are.
Even when [music] I don't see it, you're
working. Even when I don't feel it,
you're working.
Never stop.
Never stop. Never stop.
Even [music] when I don't see [singing]
it, you're working. Even when I don't
feel that you're working. Never stop.
Never stop working. Never stop. [music]
No.
[singing] Even when I don't see it,
you're working. Even when I don't
[music] feel it, you're working.
[singing]
You never stop. Never stop working.
[music]
Never stop. You never stop working. Even
when I don't see it, you're working.
Even when I [music and singing] don't
feel it, you're working. You never stop.
You never stop working. You never stop.
No
[singing and music]
way. Make a miracle worker, promise
keeper, light in the darkness. [singing]
My God, that is [music] who you are.
>> You are way [music and singing] maker,
miracle worker, promise keeper, [music]
light in [singing] the darkness. My God.
That is who you are. [singing]
That is who you are. [music]
That is who you are.
That is [music] who you are. [singing]
That is who you [singing] are. [music]
That is who you are.
[singing]
>> Even when I don't see it, you're
[singing] working. Even when I [music]
don't feel it, you're working.
You're working.
[music]
Stop. Stop again.
Mysterious Christ, your ways are higher
than our ways.
Your thoughts are higher than our
thoughts.
There is [music] an entire world of
action that we don't see.
Because we don't see that world of
action, we grow anxious.
We grow fearful.
We grow impatient,
confused, bewildered.
To trust in you and we don't see what
you're doing is
a daily thing.
So Lord, I pray for
grace upon grace
[music] on every heart with us and not
with us.
To trust
in your work and action behind the
scenes.
All the [music] ways you are working for
redemption, for healing,
for wholeness
that we don't see.
Help us to trust. [music]
Help us to try and not figure it all out
or feel like the only way we can believe
is if we can make sense of it.
Soften our hearts
and open our ears, Lord.
We ask this in your name. Amen. Before
you sit [music] down, turn to your
neighbor or if you want to walk all the
way across the room, that's cool, too.
Uh, but let's pass the peace of Christ
with each other.
Grace and peace. Welcome to the table.
So, so good to be with each and every
one of you. And as always, that includes
those joining us online. Love you all
lots. Um, my name is Brett. I'm the
pastor here. Pronouns he, him, and yeah,
it's a joy joy to welcome you into this
space and uh be with you in this uh this
Advent season. So we are uh we are in
Advent and that's our kind of current
series and uh for those unfamiliar you
know Advent is uh it's kind of a
preparation to celebrate Christmas. So
it's not quite the celebration of
Christmas per se that will come up uh
for us a week from today at our
Christmas service. Um this is yeah a
time of kind of heart and mind
preparation as we approach the the
beautiful birth uh of Jesus Christ. And
uh so the title of my message this week
is why isn't God fixing things?
And our gospel reading is Matthew
chapter 11 uh verses 2-6. Although we're
going to begin with just the first few
passages, we'll read the rest uh later
in the in the sermon. So it reads like
this. When John who was in prison heard
about the deeds of the Messiah, he sent
his disciples to ask him, that is right,
Christ, are you the one who is to come
or should we expect someone else?
Now, this is a it's an interesting
uh thing for John to ask here. And I
really appreciate
uh kind of this the beginning the kind
of vulnerability of this beginning of
the the story because here we see this
is a very different John the Baptist
than the one we encountered last week.
Uh for those who are unfamiliar with
John the Baptist, he's like a fire
brand. You know, he's a prophet and he's
like preparing the way for the Lord.
already know he's like very uh enthused
and uh so last week was I don't know we
might call it the early John even though
it's just a few years back. Um but you
know he's early in his ministry and he
was like full of vinegar and fire and uh
and kind of a certain confidence you
know and his message then was like
basically it was you know it was a
message of repentance. It was a message
of like get serious people, you know,
repent. The Messiah is coming. And if
you were here for the reading last week,
he literally says like and uh well,
there's a paraphrase my own, but
basically the Messiah is coming and he's
not going to mess around. You think I'm
intense? No, I baptize with water. He
shall baptize with fire. You know, like
this is like the early John the Baptist.
He's just like, "Yes, right. Such
passion there. commitment, zeal, you
know,
and I think, you know, something like
this vibe. I think this is uh often
true, maybe not of all of us, but many
of us kind of early in our Christian
faith or even if you came to faith later
in life, uh it could be, you know, maybe
like around the time of your baptism or
something, we were just like, yes, full
of zeal and passion and fire and you're
like out to convert everyone and you
know, I mean, just uh we get kind of in
this um this mode. So there's even a
kind of certainty that can happen and uh
and yes even perhaps we get a little
judgy you know of uh of others which I
think certainly John the Baptist could
be maybe accused of you know um pretty
pretty tough on people and you know I um
well one place where this shows up um I
think today is um Bible college. So I
mean I'm speaking out from experience.
So, if you've ever been to like a Bible
school or a Bible college or just known
people who were in that season of life,
maybe early in seminary or something, um
folks often get like this. And um
I yeah, I've definitely met some John
the Baptist types in my own little stint
at Bible colleges. Actually, Bible
college for forever because I got
married young. So, I tell people I
crammed uh four years of college into
11. So I was just forever about just
class here and there. So and it was
weird too because I went through my own
deconstruction kind of right through
that and I was like kind of there. I
took a break for a while and it was a
weird I don't know. So I still I've seen
you know I've seen it all. I've been at
Bible college 11 years let me tell you
you know um and I mean it was
fascinating like it's almost like folks
at Bible college they're they're old
enough you know have some real faith you
know I mean they're not 10 year olds or
something like there's some substance
there. um but not they've often they
tend to be young and there hasn't they
haven't had enough of life to like
really fall on their face you know or to
have that moment both in a life
experience kind of way that kind of
humiliation that comes with just life in
general if you know you know um and or
and also kind of from a faith
perspective where there is you know
they're learning things and it's easier
kind of getting a certain version of the
Bible and and the Christian faith you
know and it's just very easy to lock in
on it and like I've got the truth I got
the truth. And you start gripping it
kind of like this with fists. And you
know what happens when you form fists?
You know, you get prone to like knock
people out who don't agree. You know,
there's just kind of this thing
happening. And uh yeah, I met a lot of
John the Baptist types and uh yeah, it's
like they hadn't quite learned kind of
gone through life enough that um they
were humbled and humiliated and doubting
and maybe even having that experience
which I had uh where you have these
certain things that you're so sure of
only to later in life realize like oh
actually not only was that wrong that
was downright destructive and I probably
hurt some people. Awesome. you know,
it's just so it's not just humbling, it
is humiliating, it's, you know, it will
it will get you. And and I think um
yeah, a lot of the folks I I encountered
there at Bible college, they just hadn't
quite lived enough life yet, you know.
Um years after actually attending um I
won't say which school, but just a
school here in Dallas, I was at a local
coffee shop in Dallas. I think it must
have been in my journey, this long
11-year thing. And so, you know, I was
just there. I don't really have a lot of
reading students to be down in Dallas.
So, I'm at this coffee shop and I see
this guy. I mean, I hadn't seen him in
like eight years from the Bible college,
you know, and he's working there. And I
was kind of like, hey, you know, it's
you like what what's up? How have you
been? You know, he's like, "Oh, well."
[laughter]
He said, "Well, I'm working here."
He said, "Not my plan."
And then he said something I'll never
forget. Like this is why I think this
experience kind of stuck out my mind. He
said, "I guess that's what happens
though when you get a BA in BS."
I wasn't sure exactly what all was
behind that. I wasn't sure if just
having a Bachelor of Arts and Bible
hadn't translated well to the job
market, you know, if it was that um or
if it was kind of like a deeper like
he's just out, you know, but there was
like such a intense cynicism and I was
thinking back to who he had been, you
know, that which was like the opposite
of that. He was like all in, you know
what I mean? And it just I mean it it
just completely, you know, struck me. Um
my own path was a bit different. It took
youth ministry to put me through the
ringer. I was a youth pastor for three
years. And um I
[sighs] I don't know. There's something
about modern youth ministry. I will say
I'm thankful we're really doing our best
to do something different here at the
table. It's much like smaller, more
relational, and I just think there's
much beauty there. Um the group I led,
it was very different. Um it was large.
Uh actually to this day it is the
largest church I've ever led was my
youth pastoring [laughter] one got
Jesse. Um and we had 200 teenagers there
on a Wednesday night.
Now some of you are thinking well don't
be so pessimistic but like that's
beautiful. 200 teenagers pursuing the
Lord Jesus Christ, [laughter]
you know, just weeping. No, no. They
were there to find their next boyfriend
or girlfriend or, you know, I mean, it
was a social scene, pure and simple.
There's about I would say 5% of the
teens that really, you know, I mean,
they were really hungry for spiritual
things that, you know, I mean, but let's
be honest, like this is just what it
was. I really honestly I felt like a
babysitter. I was a babysitter for 200
people and um we did our best to create
a Christ centered atmosphere. I know
there was good that came from it of
course you know I mean I'm still in
touch with some people they were
impacted but at the same time it just
put me through the ring. I was so
discouraged. I was preaching like this,
but it was sort of the early days of
cell phones. And I mean, the teens,
they're just on their phones and like
I'm just not. At one time, Maggie tells
a story. Um, [laughter] she was just
sitting on the front row and all of a
sudden a condom comes flying and just
lands on her lap, thankfully unused.
That was a win, I guess. Um, and just
like, what is going on? It was just out
of control. And by the end of the three
years, I was just so discouraged and
just disappointed. And and of course,
not everyone, but certain people around
me were like, "No, but it's beautiful.
Look at all the people and it's because
you're so anointed, you know?" And I was
just like, [sighs]
"No,
if this is what church is, like if this
I just
I mean, by the end of that, that's what
kind of sent me into my deconstruction
journey. I was just like, I got to
figure something out. We What ARE WE
DOING HERE? WHAT ARE we doing here? You
know, the youth group down the down the
streets passing out Nikes, you know.
Hey, come on kids. You want some Nikes?
Come to find God. I just God bless. What
are we doing? You know.
Yeah.
Have you um I wonder though like have
you been there maybe in your own way,
you know? I mean, Bible college or
whatever, but just in your own way, have
you been there in that moment of just so
freaking discouraged? like just I had a
vision of this is this is what life is
or this is how my life's going to go or
this is what ministry is or this is what
church is or this is you know this is
where we need to go and then it's just
like it's all freaking falling apart and
it's so discouraging you know and you
wonder just like my friend you know is
it all just BS
you know whether that's kind of literal
like Christian faith is all just BS you
know or in a more generic is life just a
mess you know what I mean like is
Is it all just BS? So, in other words, I
think it's it's not unusual, you know,
to find ourselves like John the Baptist
sitting in the cell of our own questions
and doubts and confusions.
You know, you'll uh notice in the
passage that uh John, you know, he's no
longer in the desert, is he preaching to
the masses, you know, being a minor
celebrity of sorts. No, no, no, no. the
the political winds have shifted now and
they've shifted against him. Now he's in
prison and he's so discouraged like he's
not even sure if Jesus is who he thought
he was. Like how do you get there from
like prepare the way for the Lord and
he's the guy and I'm so excited. I'm all
you know what I mean to
I'm really not I don't even know like is
this I I'm not even I'm not even sure.
Are you like you the one we should
expect or should it be like someone you
know someone else?
Uh we pick up the story verse four uh
Jesus this is Jesus response to John
when John sends these disciples you know
to ask are you the one Jesus replied go
back and report to John what you hear
and what you see blind receive sight the
lame walk those who have leprosy are
cleansed the deaf hear the dead are
raised and the good news is proclaimed
to the poor. He says this interesting
line, "Blessed is anyone who does not
stumble on account of me."
It's an interesting little ending there,
isn't it? Blessed is anyone who does not
stumble on account of me.
What's he getting at? I I think it's
something like this.
The gap between my expectation for how
God works in the world and how God
actually works in the world is much
larger than I'd like to admit.
Maybe you could say like God here seems
to be playing the long game and I am
not. You know what I mean? Like I'm
playing the short game. I need change
and I need it now for for me, for
others, for the world honestly. You
know, we got to turn this thing around.
Let's get going. You know what I mean?
Uh, in fact, you could even maybe say
Jesus is maybe even just playing the
long. It's like he's just playing like a
different game entirely, you know, like
he's not even trying to win at my game.
And and what is my game? I don't know.
Well, let's start with even the culture.
Just the game of the culture. This is
certainly not a game Jesus is playing.
The game of money, the game of power,
the game of success in the political,
social, and here's where it translates
to church and the religious spheres. You
know, we have our own visions of success
and this is what it looks like and this
is how it should be and this is how
church should be and this is how people
should be and you know we have our whole
plan and this is what God should be up
to is really what God ought to be doing
you know and it's just like [laughter]
not how it is.
There was another time where Jesus was
asked uh what is your kingdom like like
what's this you know you're talking
about your kingdom what's it what's it
like you know and there was a certain
irony as uh Charles preached on a few
weeks ago with the language of kingdom
and such there's a certain irony in
Jesus using this language of kingdom
because we start imagining like kings
with power and hierarchy and and then
Jesus just completely subverts that you
know so he says what's my kingdom like
you know my kingdom well he said it's
like a it's like a like a little mustard
seed. It's like so small, but then over
time, just give it time, it just grows
and grows and grows and grows and grows,
and before you know it, it's like
swallowed up the whole garden. And he
said, "What's uh what's my what's my
kingdom like? It's like a It's like
yeast and dough. It's like hidden. You
can't you can't even see it." and just
slowly just like works its way through
the dough until before you know it's all
like bubbling and thoroughly infused.
You know,
like in other words, there's this kind
of picture of uh how does the kingdom
work? It's this like subtle, quiet
um process. It's like behind the scenes,
you know. And I don't know about you,
but this is not how I want to work.
You know, this is this is not how I want
God to work. I I want like quick results
and I want them I want them now. I want
them now. This is what uh this kingdom
that Jesus came to establish. This is
what uh the theologian Alan Krider, he
called it the patient ferment of the
early church. I like that term of
phrase, patient ferment of the early
church. you can get there kind of the
yeast and dough kind of language with
ferment and you know it's this kind of
subtle hidden uh mysterious kind of
process you know especially for in the
ancient world they didn't really
understand how this stuff is fermenting
they just know weirdly it just does you
know it's it's kind of there's a mystery
there and uh if you look at how the
church grew in its first 400 years it
really is quite remarkable because it
was all like and think even specifically
just around in and around Rome it was
all like subtle and behind the scenes
and mostly invisible. I mean, the church
just didn't go out courting, you know,
the high and mighty and trying to
basically kind of win the elites and
then by getting the elites in power,
then influence, you know, I mean, the
rest and kind of get everyone else on
board like no, it kind of started there
at the bottom, so to speak. started with
the, you know, the lost and the the meek
and the marginalized and, you know, it's
this very different way of working and
and uh and just slowly through the years
um it you know it grew, right? Like just
like like the yeast and dough like the
the little mustard seed that's so tin
you couldn't if I was holding it you
couldn't even see it and yet it takes
over the whole garden. Like this is how
God works. Obscure, quiet, humble,
patient.
In fact, it's interesting to think. I
wonder if some of John's own wrestlings
were that uh I'm speculating here, but I
wonder if he really wanted Jesus to like
knock out those Romans, you know, or
like really establish like not a
metaphorical spiritual, you know, uh
kind of kingdom, like a literal kingdom,
like warriors and you know what I mean?
Like, and I wonder if he really wanted
that. And it's it's interesting that uh
in many ways you could say Jesus
ultimately did conquer Rome
back to that patient firmament of the
early church. I mean if you know some of
your church history uh it's it just took
about 400 years and no sword was ever
raised
which is interesting you know instead
actually the Roman leaders they came to
the church and asked for help. Now, we
can argue that at that point they the
church should have said no because
that's the Constantinian compromise and
you got this whole long history of
Christendom and there's a whole thing
you know uh fair enough like you can
name that you know I mean I think that's
a viable they should have said no maybe
um but it is interesting that that in
essence uh Rome wasn't conquered by you
know violent Christian revolutionaries
who just like grabbed power for Christ
you know or something no it was the
leaders begged the church for help. And
that's actually how Rome conquered. You
see,
when we're discouraged by the lack of
spiritual maturity and progress in
ourselves or in the church or in the
broader culture, I I think this is where
we must learn to um start looking for
the signs, you know, inbreakings, little
inbreakings of the kingdom, places where
healing, life, forgiveness, and hope are
happening, right? Because this is what
Jesus said, right? This was his response
to John was, "Let me tell you the signs.
Let me let me tell you what's
happening." Right? There's there's these
places of healing, places of hope,
places of forgiveness. The the poor
being treated rightly. You know what I
mean? Like it's this is the sign that
it's working, that God's up to
something.
But in essence, um, we miss it, right?
Because we're not always looking to
those exact same signs.
I I wonder though um part of my job as
like a pastor is to walk with people and
one thing I just want to name for all of
us is that I see the work of God in you.
Like I know as you're living your life
it's it's hard to see it. You know what
I mean? You're just like I don't think
so. [laughter]
But that's the beauty. I swear to you I
see it. I see I see those little mustard
seeds. I see the signs of the kingdom
like happening in you. Like it is it is
so clear. I mean one just to take one
example. I won't pick on like anyone.
I'm not don't worry. I'm not going to
suddenly name a name or something. Um
but one for example, one thing I've seen
is so many people come through these
doors with so much unprocessed um
bitterness and anger at God.
And uh and I won't even defend that, you
know, or say like you shouldn't have
been like, "No, a lot of it was kind of,
you know, there was there was real hurt
there, you know what I mean?" So, I'm
not even trying to downplay it. But it
was also true that that anger was eating
you alive.
That bitterness was like robbing you.
And it is so beautiful. I've just seen
this in person after person after person
over. How does it happen? I don't know.
That's the mystery. I don't exactly know
how it's working or what's going on. But
somehow through the I wish it were weeks
I mean or days but it is years usually
through the years it's like God just
starts to do this work. How it happens I
do not know but it is beautiful and holy
and good. And I see it happening in you.
I see it in sweet Vicky Ferris.
Uh many of you knew her. Um the the
woman who was here with usually had the
walker and the blue hair or different
color hair. Um just a lovely lovely
woman and uh she passed away last week.
And um you know I don't think well or I
know she she was well she was not only a
beloved member of our community but I
know she didn't think of herself as like
extraordinary in any way you know or
like special or she just did she did not
um but if you knew her you know she
absolutely was like she was on this uh
journey was Parkinson's is ultimately um
what just kind of broken her body and uh
and she was working you could just so
hard like not to get just embittered
and deeply just pessimistic and like she
was and and if you encountered her, you
knew like she had how how a certain joy
about her. You know what I mean? Like a
kind word for others like in the midst
of this just decimating disease like
unbelievable. It's incredible. I've seen
the same thing in her daughter Whitney
and I did get her permission to share
this by the way. this um that the
journey she's been on like caring for
her mother really these last few years
especially the last few months though
where she's really stepped up to walk
with her and if you know Whitney and
some of her story like she was a wild
child growing up um wild [laughter] you
can ask her for she'll tell you some
amazing stories um and it's incredible
to see
like how that kind of fierceness
and uh and really honestly kind of wild
like courage was been like kind of
funneled into this kind of fierce
commitment and love for her mother and
her children.
And to see her walk that out the last
months and especially the last few weeks
like has been incredible. Like that's
like that's it. That's that's the little
imbreings. That's the the signs, right?
Look for the little look for the
healing. Look for the hope. Look for the
forgiveness. Look for the mercy. Look
look for the compassion. Like just start
to notice where it's happening.
Uh one last example I'll share because
this isn't limited to the table of
course is that every other year we
attend uh many of us here and it
actually be coming up in October so I
encourage you all to attend. It's the
centerpiece conference uh hosted by an
organization called centerpiece which is
a basically kind of an LGBTQ affirming
um uh ministry that's trying to really
connect with church folks, people who've
been hurt by the church and the LGBTQ
community. It's run by Sally Gary. Yeah,
we have her picture up there. Uh some of
you know Sally and uh she was basically
when she started this organization like
20 years ago, she was pretty much a lone
voice in the Churches of Christ kind of
denomination
basically naming like hey
we we got an issue here like th this is
these these you know gay kids and
lesbian kids and um trans kids like and
people like this isn't some like issue
out there somewhere. we're abstractly in
the world or something like that. She
basically just named for the church like
it was a sort of uncomfortable truth FOR
THEM. SHE SAID this is us. It is us.
We're not talking about them. This is
our children and the people in our small
groups and in in you our Sunday school
classes and sitting next to us in our
sanctuary. Like this is us and we we
need to acknowledge this. And and she
just I mean was so incredibly courageous
to step out and start this move. And now
I'm at that conference and it's every
other year and I'm there and I just
can't believe there's like 5 to 600
people gathered and the like the energy
in that room, the passion, the love, it
is incredible. And I just the multiple
times I've been there now, I just stand
there on like the opening night and I'm
like I can't believe it. Like how is God
doing this thing? This this is
incredible. And here in Texas, like I'm
like [laughter] this is a miracle. It's
I mean it's just another example of just
a little embreaking. Just a little
embrace. Just this light bursts forth.
This love bursts forth. This this uh
compassion,
this healing it starts to happen. It's
just beautiful, beautiful, beautiful to
witness, right? It's a sign of the
kingdom. And uh in closing though, like
I get it, right? Life beats us up. Um,
like John, man, we just get beat down
and we're just discouraged. Many of you
are there tonight. You're just just flat
out discouraged and
as Jesus kind of named, uh, we stumble,
you know, we stumble, we doubt, we're
just like, I'm [snorts] just not sure
about, you know, any of this. And we
become frustrated with the slowness, the
slowness of the growth and the
transformation in ourselves, in the
church, in the world. And yet, it's
beautiful. Jesus is so gentle in his
response to us. Which is why in Matthew
11, you'll notice he didn't, what did he
not say to John or well to John's little
followers that, you know, were sending
the message. We're going to take it back
to him. He didn't tell them like, well,
you tell John I absolutely am the
Messiah and he better not doubt again.
You know, like no, no, no. This
[laughter]
is not how Jesus responds, right?
Instead, what do you say? You tell John,
just tell him what you see and tell him
what you hear.
Look at the healing. Look at the
cleansing. Look at how the lowly and the
marginalized are treated. And listen,
listen to the forgiving and loving
speech. This is what it looks like when
God is at work. So, how does the kingdom
happen? How does it how does it happen
in our in my life and our in the church
and the soc broader society? Has it
happened? Well, slowly.
You say why slowly? Well, because the
other option is quickly, which is to say
coercively, forcefully, violently.
[laughter]
And that's not how God has chosen to
work. We might say that this this love
the kingdom, it moves at the pace of
relationship,
right? both God's relationship to us, us
and our relationship to others. And so I
say thanks be to God, you know, thanks
be to God. That's the kind of Messiah
Jesus was. It's the kind of kingdom he
initiates. God is patient. Oh, patient.
Patient with me, patient with the
church, with the broader culture. I
think our job is just to take a deep
breath
and trust. Trust that God is at work. In
the name of the Father, the Son, and the
Holy Spirit. Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held a little of
bread and he broke it. And he said,
"Take this, eat. This is my body. It's
broken for you."
And then he held up a cup of wine. He
said, "Take this, drink. This is my
blood. it shed for you. Whenever you eat
this bread, whenever you drink this cup,
remember me.
And so, as we come forward tonight,
that's what we're doing. We're
remembering and in a mysterious way,
we're participating in the Christ who
has promised to be present uh to us in
this bread and cup. And so I encourage
you as you come forward to uh come with
that that kind of an expectation to
receive something to receive a little
encouragement, receive a little life
healing, a little little embreaking of
the kingdom for uh for you. So uh the
way we'll go about this is we'll just go
rowby row starting here at the front
forming a line here in uh in the middle.
We practice an open table. So if you're
here tonight, you want to participate,
feel free to do that regardless of your
exact, you know, beliefs or theology or
denomination or whatever. Um, if you
want to come forward and receive and
connect with Christ in this way, then do
that. Just know the red is wine, the
white is grape juice. And finally, you
can just partake whenever and however uh
you'd like. No one will lead you through
the exact moment of taking. So this is
the table,
not of the church,
but of the Lord. And it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more. So come you who
have much faith and you who have little.
You who have been here often and you who
have not been here long. You who have
tried to follow and you who feel like
you've failed. Come. Come because it's
the Lord Jesus himself who invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here. Come to
the table.
>> [music]
>> If you'd like to join us as we stand to
close, we're going to close with way
maker. [music]
I think singing these words together as
we leave will be good.
Even when I don't see it, you're
working. Even when [singing] I don't
feel it, you're working. [music] You
never stop. You never stop working.
Never [music and singing] stop. You
never stop working. Even when I don't
see it, you're working. Even [music]
when I [singing] don't feel it, you're
working. You never stop. Never stop
[music] working. Never stop. Never stop.
God, way maker, miracle worker, [music]
promise keeper, light in [singing] the
darkness. My God, that is who [music]
you are.
You are [singing] way maker, miracle
worker, promise [music] keeper, light in
the darkness. My God, that is who you
are. [music and singing]
That is who you are.
That is who you [music and singing] are.
That [music] is who you are.
That is [singing] who you are. [music]
That is who you are.
[singing] That is [music] who you are.
>> [music]
>> Thank you so much for joining us this
evening. If you're new, we would love
for you to fill [music] out a card for
us. It's on the table here to my left on
your way out or [music] also you can
scan the QR code which should be coming
up on the screen behind me.
If you call the table home but you
[music] don't currently serve on a
ministry team, we would love to have you
try one out. Tech team, kids [music]
ministry, host team are currently the
ones that are in the most need. So you
can fill out a table on the card again
[music] to my left or also scan that QR
code.
Generosity is a key aspect [music] of a
life of adoration and worship. If the
table is your church home, then we would
invite you to scan that QR code and give
financially or you can also give by
visiting tabletx.org.
All right, let me send to you into your
week with [music] this blessing. You can
hold out your hands and posture to
receive or just open your heart.
You are a [music] child of God.
You are a child of God.
This is true on your best day and it is
true on your worst.
So as you go into your week with its yet
[music] to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between, go filled
with the assurance that you are loved,
you are worthy, and you are accepted
just as [music] you are. and go filled
with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
[music] extend these same gifts of grace
and unconditional love to everyone you
come into contact with. Thanks everyone.
[music]
>> You are [singing] way maker, miracle
worker, [music] promise keeper, light in
[singing] the darkness. My [music] God,
that is who you are. [singing]
You are [music] way maker, miracle
worker, promise [singing] keeper, light
in [music] the darkness. My God,
[singing] that is who you [music] are.
That is who you [singing] are.
That is who you [music] are.
That is who you are.
[music and singing] That is who you are.